by hi hi Lauren Zima heart disease
Hanabi is coming at you
first and foremost are you happy to be
done with virginity jokes we're not
quite done Oh is there a virgin on this
season well there's I mean here's the
thing there's things that happened last
season when you're the Bachelorette are
gonna come back this season because guys
think it's clever so there's you know
the inevitable Colton references okay
okay so no virgin yeah there might be oh
okay
I stopped asking all right well you know
those conversations never there's still
virgin jokes and virgin pina coladas
that kind of stuff you could cut that
picture of tension with a knife
well Hanna on coal the season was Hannah
beast how much does she live up to the
Hannah beasts nickname I mean
unfortunately too much you know it
literally starts night one with the drum
this there is more drama man drama this
season we've ever had before it I'm not
saying it's the most dramatic season
ever yet but I am saying there's more
man drama and it starts night 1 where
she's like oh really okay she's in what
does the man drama mean does that mean
tears does that mean fistfights yeah yes
and yes yeah our ambulance is called
yeah on night one no okay one who's not
an evil it's like wait no there's not an
ambulance on night one but there there
really is it's in there's different
levels of man drama there's man drama
that there's just the guy not there for
the right reasons then there's the guy
who just is the guys that you know just
rub everyone the wrong way that everyone
loves to hate and it's stuff that she
just has to deal with constantly and
every time we think we're over it it
rears its ugly head and she has to get
back in it and it really got to the
point where honestly it started taking
away from her being the Bachelorette it
took away from the entire season and a
chance for her to find love and it may
cause her to not find love at the end of
this well Colton's season ending was
very unconventional I know you're about
to go film it but how unconventional do
you think Hannah's ending will be I
don't know I mean it's it's already
unconventional heading into it just
sitting here now typically you know
yeah you know it's smooth sailing we're
gonna you know there might be a little
bump in the road but we're gonna lay on
this thing and she's gonna be engaged or
he's gonna be engaged sitting here now I
don't I really don't know how it's gonna
end I'm hopeful and she's hopeful but
the way she wants to find love and the
way she's going about this is really
true and sincere and she's not gonna
just do it to do it and as rough as it's
been and as wild as it's been I'm not
sure she's gonna be able to get there
and that's because she doesn't know if
she's gonna be able to get there so I'm
interested as anybody to see how this
all wraps up so no guarantee on a
proposal for Hannah B right now no I
wish I could guarantee it but I cannot
deliver I don't know I can't I would
love to be able to do my job and deliver
this but I don't know if we're going to
know it might be a bumpy finish he just
jumped the fence well I know Hannah
didn't in her heels jump offense but
what is Hannah's fence jump moment what
is the drama pinnacle what can you tease
I mean I would probably say it is the
drama it is the man drama in in what I
mean by that is you're gonna see drama
along the way let's say it's a level two
drama this is a level ten drama that
really Fester's and really dives into
the fabric of this show and I think it's
gonna shape this entire show because it
has to do with somebody she really cares
about and so it's not something that's
just gonna go away somebody she really
cares about does that mean our first
impression Rose get her because those
guys tend to stick around on the
Bachelorette I don't even remember who
got the first impression yes yes okay
sure
all right well why do you think so much
man drama more than ever before I mean
you know I guess the only thing you can
say is is it's Hannah I mean there it's
it's who's at the center of this it's
who they're chasing after it's who's
kind of running this program so it's got
to be the prize at the end of this and
obviously you have these strong
charismatic type-a guys that are gonna
you know you always have drama when you
have 30 guys but this is different it
really is at a different level and again
I think a lot of it has to do with the
fact that instead of going away it gets
worse and then
instead of dealing with it it rears its
ugly head again and just gets worse and
worse so it's this kind of like snowball
effect of every time we would wrap up
you know a cocktail party a rose
ceremony like next week it's gonna be
different clean slate and it wasn't a
clean slate sounds like maybe Hannah
should have sent some guys home that she
didn't well I don't know if that's see
that I don't know it's correct and
that's where this thing gets tricky and
it gets muddy because I don't know if
that's correct either because you don't
know is this is this guys being dramatic
are these guys that are being jealous
because you know Hannah only in people
have to understand Hannah gets to see
what she gets to see in that's it it's
not like we sit back and show her tapes
of everything else going around so she
only can judge from what she sees and
she likes what she sees well night one
you're doing kind of a game-changing
move bringing Demi and Katie into this
surveillance van how much does that
affect everything well it's gonna be
interesting to see if that has a ripple
effect on seasons to come
because now will everybody think come on
being watch but they should know they're
always being watched but yeah we brought
in Damien and Katie who are two of her
best friends from last season and we
have a little bit of a surveillance
situation where they are revealing some
things to to Hanna later on in the
evening on night one and they reveal a
pretty big nugget most dramatic night
one ever Wow gosh let me think it's a
good one I need to think I need to think
back in the memory bank I don't know if
it's the most traumatic Nate one ever
Courtney just popped in hard but it's
pretty it's a pretty badass night one
okay yeah [ __ ] well the good thing I
think if you were worried about if
you're at all worried about the
Bachelorette that Hannah was going to be
and I think we all were after the after
the final rose special it was a little
rocky on that live special that's being
very generous I was scared to death she
came in as the Bachelorette just firing
on all cylinders took control there was
an incident on night one I'll say thanks
to Demi and Katie that I thought okay
this this might be where I need to step
in because Hannah's not really ready for
this yet
and she just likes it I got this well
you guys also did something different
you released the guys earlier than ever
before right and then a couple of them I
don't think made it to premiere night
right why was that was that to suss out
some problem children because the show
is not a stranger to scandal right but
no I here's the thing everybody and this
is a little behind the scenes but
everybody we bring in to be on the
bachelor or the Bachelorette doesn't
make it to the show and so we always
have and it's a terrible word I don't
know what the word to call because I
hate to say they're extras they're not
extras they're all great guys or great
women but at the end of the day as
producers we have to sit down and we
think through the dates we think through
the beats we think through the hours of
televisions that ABC has given us and
thing how many guys can we have and then
we start fighting over our favorites of
who's gonna be a good story do we have
too many guys from Los Angeles do we
have too many from New York and do we
need to well I really I'm so early this
year well I think part of that too is
because of social media and and what
that is brought to the table for sure
does this season have a scandal always
what can you tell there's drama there's
scandal
yeah of course we have a question for
you I'm we're doing a piece on helps
that we are that the bachelor world has
never won an Emmy won an Emmy
we've never been nominated for an Emmy
yeah but I feel like I feel like it's
only been 17 years 23 seasons 15 seasons
it's only the most successful television
franchise arguably in the history of
television probably created more hours
of TV than any franchise in the history
of television so why get an Emmy
well it doesn't bother you and why do
you think there has never been a
nomination I I mean I don't know who the
hell knows why I really don't know I
don't know how that even works I've
never I've never been to the Emmys I've
never been on the stage at the Emmys
I've never been I've been nominated for
two Daytime Emmys millionaire I'm
looking at you thanks for that no I
think it's a host of things I think when
they win that when the reality TV
category came around we had been on for
several years so we
a little bit long in the tooth and there
were some newer cooler hipper kids on
the block and then there was this
strange thing we're Amazing Race won
like 90 Emmys and no one really knew why
and there was that and then I think
would become cool again and relevant but
maybe we're just too old no one likes
the old people that's not true we're
just always smelling oculist why do you
think you're into this thing I think
that the Oscars treat superhero movies
in the same way that Emmys treat great
reality television I want any noms for
the bachelor and housewives and that's
how I feel about it so what Xena is
saying is I am Iron Man
okay three guys to watch for this season
and why John Paul Jones because I love
saying bond John Paul Jones and you have
to use his full name he won't let you
and he refers to himself in the third
person as John Paul Jones and if you're
too young to know this movie just go
watch Fast Times at Ridgemont High and
you'll see Spicoli I love them let's see
there's two pilots meaning men who are
pilots not say five points of television
exactly so don't think in despair yeah
they're not pilots trying to be picked
up for ABC another actual pilots at fly
planes I would say keep an eye on Peter
he's you know wears the uniform shows up
on night one Big Mike is just this
adorable endearing lovable lovable
character who just he's these that guy
in the house that everybody likes but is
he that guy in the house that everyone
just likes you know what I mean is he
friend zone material and then let's go
la Dylan it is done right let's go la
Dylan because of who Hannah is family
down-home roots loves that that is Dylan
he has an amazing story that he'll share
and he's quiet and Kanye's in the
background but not so much that he's
like who's that guy he's just that guy
that's always there and he shares this
he's kind of the mirror image of who
Hannah is and obviously that's a
comfortable thing to see great give me
four guys appreciate it one word to
describe Hannah's season
drama-filled it's - eh - aidid ID I did
I make that up I can't believe you said
drama I'm shocked no not what is the
most dramatic I'm its drama
Phil this is different you got to
believe me this is different this time
I'm a normal human being I trying to be
the Bachelorette I don't know what to do
and I'm scared